it's tough for me to memorize things in
English and I've been speaking at my
entire life in Game of Thrones for the
role of Drogo and Daenerys Jason Momoa
and Emilia Clarke had to learn a whole
language called Dothraki when you hear
it spoken is not just a bunch of
gibberish it's actual words with meaning
it so we decided we are gonna challenge
ourselves to learn Dothraki and speak it
while we recreate this famous scene from
Game of Thrones Oh stick it on throne
chicopee Cassie ask you the Cadi fish
sauce ringmaster
the goal is simple we're gonna give
ourselves one week to learn sixty
Seconds to dialogue and at the end of
the seven days we're gonna try to
recreate this team but before we begin
we're going to talk to David Peterson
who's the creator of the Dothraki
language so living language Dothraki is
kind of a crash course on Dothraki it
tells you everything that you need to
know about the grammar did you at any
point work with any of the actors
learning the language themselves I
recorded every single line on mp3 for
the show every single line that you've
heard I've already said it dozens of
times and they've listened to dozens of
times in mp3 video sub vessel one a
summer song as long as you pronounce it
correctly you're speaking Dothraki Drogo
Key Lime OC same language how would you
say BuzzFeed in Dothraki was do you
think we could memorize it within a week
come on you guys are good
[Music]
raishin just give us an asterisk so okay
so right now I am literally watching the
scene stopping it and trying to get the
correct pronunciation for the script
it's gonna be a lot harder than I
thought
I'm trying to read these lines in here
take a little bit of time to see if this
helps
I'm not feeling very confident with what
I've learned at all but I need to clean
the house so what I decided to do was I
actually recorded the scene on my phone
and I'm gonna listen to it and my
headphones instead of listening to music
and maybe that'll help me memorize it
today we're doing a dress rehearsal
let's see if Chris is ready I've spotted
him Chris are you ready for a dress
rehearsal I need the first couple words
of the first line and then it just rolls
the second line
ooh the point is I definitely need the
rehearsal both thousand hours of rap
from the top sewer force or not gosh
al-aziz rushy
sec tell you this d say do you say
I think we're actually so today is the
last day to learn these lines got about
24 hours to have everything locked in
I'm a little bit worried because my
brain is not soaking these things in
like I thought it would slept like the
Daenerys Queen that I am because today
is the big day and I'm in full character
and we are going to crush it it probably
took us about 60 or 70 takes to get it
right actually there were points where
we became delirious it's very hard to
keep the pronunciation correct so braid
your hair try to not laugh are you it's
very robotic so if you look a lot of the
time we're just like dead in the eyes we
only got one solid no mistake take of
the sixty Seconds ambush
this VIN Sasha races rage Beausoleil
order room she Cathy Cathy
Adhikari Vasia daughter in the home
Masha sorry
so for Soren Akasha Ava's EEP Casca bow
Arabella Yama empathise so we saw naka
with such a sorry Sophie Caillou
so we saw Ari or her eonni boss or foe
reishi rice sack the recovery if we it
so may the female DNA Keisha Bosto
Chivas Alex's video Midori Cecchetti
miss adore mei mei throne Tyrone adore
fee nan Carl Karcher so che che Khaleesi
called bones take a day or a Tarun enemy
so means they get a suitor soon d say
[Music]